Apollo Creed is the most important
person to every great Rocky movie bro
you're black yeah
um
first of all Rocky
centered around Apollo Creed every
single one the first Rocky movie they
fight at the end of the movie It's to
draw Rocky gets to fight again for the
championship in Rocky too so both of
those the central figure is Apollo third
move Club of land comes Rocky's Rich he
loses all his Mojo football club Elaine
who motivates him and gets him back in
the shade Apollo Creed
then and Rocky IV what happened Apollo
gets killed by the Russian so now Rocky
has motivation to go to Russia and fight
Rocky after that them Rocky movies fell
apart why are they able to make a Creed
because free Apollo is the central
figure of all right might not be the
central figure but he drives everything
he's the main catalyst for all those
catalysts you can't make any of those
films without Apollo Creed